no issue is more controversial
and confusing than the right to free
speech especially when it's pitted
against the desire of people not to feel
attacked or hated
simply because of their race gender or
sexual orientation
nadine strassen who served as the
president of the aclu from 1991 to 2008
is the author of the new book hate why
we should resist it with free
speech not censorship the book lays out
a compelling argument against laws and
policies
that try to restrict what individuals
are allowed to say
strassen is the daughter of a holocaust
survivor and in 1978
the organization she would go on to lead
famously defended the rights of
neo-nazis to march through skokie
a chicago suburb with a large jewish
population
many residents of skokie were survivors
of german death camps
who argued that the psychic pain of a
nazi rally would be brutally upsetting
and could lead to violence as the aclu's
brief in that case noted
the arguments for stopping the march
were the exact same as those made ten
years earlier
by the residents of cicero illinois who
sued to stop
martin luther king from leading a civil
rights demonstration in their tent
strassen is now a professor at new york
law school in manhattan
she sat down recently with reason to
talk about her new book
why hyper polarization in american
politics makes free speech even more
difficult
and what are the best ways to counter
bad stupid and hate-filled speech
nadine strassen thanks for talking to
reason i'm delighted to be here
so what form do hate speech laws take
today
and why should we be worried about them
in the united states we do not allow
speech to be censored merely because its
message is deemed to be hateful
or hated by those who wield power
however
speech with a hated or hateful message
along with speech that conveys
any other message may be punished if
in a certain context it directly
causes specific imminent serious harm
such as a
true threat or intentional incitement of
imminence punishable
incitement so if you say as there was a
famous case
uh there's a white guy let's go get him
exactly that's
different if you can write and if i can
clarify
it's different from the way we use
inciting rather loosely in everyday
speech it's an appropriately strict
standard
the speaker has to intend to incite
imminent violent or lawless conduct that
is likely to happen imminently
so and and this is like you can write
like i
uh you know hitler was great on a brick
that might be
objectionable but it's not hate speech
if you throw that brick
through somebody's window that's a
punishable it could be a so-called hate
crime or bias crime unlike hate speech
hate crime or bias crime is an
acceptable legal
concept and what it means is you take
something that would be a crime
otherwise apart from its message your
example of throwing a brick is
at least property damage and probably
assault as well
if uh you could the government can show
that that
victim of the crime was singled out for
a discriminatory reason such as race
religion or so forth
then it can be treated as a hate crime
or bias crime
and subject to a stiffer penalty
on the theory that it causes more harm
both to the victim
and to society but i would be careful so
in the united states
even though the supreme court has
consistently struck down
laws that punish speech based on its
hateful content and i have to stress the
supreme court justices
across the entire ideological spectrum
from left to right
have agreed that that is a bedrock
principle
of freedom of speech we can't punish it
just because we despise the viewpoint
nonetheless like a lot of uh human
rights principles and civil liberties
principles
this one is honored in the breach in
many contexts so we have
many college campuses that actually are
enforcing
hate speech codes for all practical
purposes they
don't label them as such anymore ever
since
the aclu and fire and others have
successfully challenged every single
hate speech code
but under the guise of rules about
civility
on campus or very distorted exaggerated
concepts of
harassment racial and and gender
harassment
colleges are in fact punishing ideas
merely because they are offensive and
cause
students to be or faculty be
uncomfortable you you
go back and you look at places where
hate speech laws were put in place and
they end up
harming the very people they were
supposedly trying to protect and you
talk about
a 1965 british law that was designed to
go after a neo-nazi group
and it ended up being used to punish the
anti-nazi league
how common is that where you know they
you kind of get hoist on your own petard
it's
uh all hate speech laws
like all laws are disproportionately
enforced
against those who lack political power
in a democratic society it's not
surprising just the way the drug laws
are disproportionately enforced against
young dark-skinned men and the problem
is even more acute nick when we're
talking about hate speech laws
because the concept is inherently
irreducibly subjective hate is
an emotion and what one person hates
somebody else
loves we see that you know in today's
society for example
many politicians and other powerful
people have denounced
black lives matter advocacy as hate
speech
against white people or against police
officers it's even been
accused of causing assassinations of
police
officers whereas other people denounce
blue lives matter as hate speech or all
lives matter
as hate speech so given this inevitable
subjectivity
those who enforce the law really have
unfettered discretion to
enforce their own values about what is
hateful and what is dangerous and so
forth
and they're not good they're they're
accountable to the majority
they're not likely to enforce those laws
to the benefit
of dissenters or minority groups
you uh you mentioned a case a late 1980s
case at the university of michigan where
for i guess
one or two years they had a hate speech
law in place and it was used to punish a
black
grad student who thought homosexuality
was a mental illness
and he developed as part of a project
like a way basically to convert gays to
heterosexuality
so you're saying that's more it's it's
not just like oh that happens on the
fringes that almost
always happens and you know not only
does it almost always happen nick and
there are many examples that are going
on today
uh in europe and canada and all the
other countries that do enforce hate
speech laws democratic countries i mean
in the totalitarian authoritarian
countries it's blatantly singling out
their political opponents
uh but the fact that this happens really
follows from the analysis of those who
advocate hate speech laws they argue
that we live in a society
that has uh endemic problems of
structural
and systemic racism including and other
forms of discrimination
including in the criminal justice system
i agree
with that critique they argue that all
of us living in this society and culture
are subject to
unintended bias unconscious bias i agree
therefore i completely reject the
vaunted solution
of handing over to that discriminatory
system
and discriminatory individuals the power
to pick and choose according to their
own values and the values of the
majority
which speech is going to be silenced and
i one of the interesting things that i
learned from doing this
book because i'm so used to being
accused of american
exceptionalism which by the way if we're
exceptional in our defense of free
speech i re
wear that criticism like a badge of
honor uh but i thought what was so
interesting is that so many human rights
activists in other countries that
enforce hate speech laws
have become so critical of those laws as
they see
how ineffective they are at best and
counterproductive at worst in terms of
the very human rights goals and
equality goals they were hoping to
advance
your book focuses a lot on government
censorship for for a lot of reasons but
you also talk about how much of our
speech and expression now takes place in
in either private places like workplaces
or private schools things like that
or kind of semi-private situations
online intermediaries like facebook uh
twitter and youtube
when mark zuckerberg the head of
facebook testified before congress
recently he talked a lot about how great
you know how important it was for
facebook to police hate speech
um you talk a lot about how facebook
though
has done a lot of stuff that ends up
hurting the minorities that it seems to
be protecting
and you tend to argue or you argue kind
of if
i'm reading it right your first argument
is that you know basically private
places should adopt robust first
amendment
speech restrictions why is that okay so
first of all i have to explain to your
listeners what you obviously know but
most people don't that
the first amendment along with most
constitutional rights guarantees
has no binding effect at all
on any private sector entities including
private sector
campuses and certainly these online
powerful companies
that does not mean that we should not
use other tools to try to secure
free speech values when they exercise so
much practical power
whether we in fact have a free exchange
of ideas or not so
i and others have been trying to
advocate
uh against suppression of hate speech
even on on on
facebook and so forth even though
they're facing enormous political and
public pressure to do the opposite
but how facebook for example has
enforced its hate speech rules
to me nick is a textbook illustration
of the inevitable problems how
inevitably vague and subjective the
standards are
leading to results that are arbitrary
and capricious at best
outright discriminatory at worst talk
about how
they ended up banning lgbt groups that
used the words dike and [ __ ]
which can counter speech calling out the
hate speech for purposes
of uh denouncing the hate mongers and
offering support to its victims
has been censored now i have to say in
its defense facebook responds to these
criticisms and i
saw that recently they said they are
revising their standards
so that they will try to protect
instances of
hateful messages being repeated for
denunciatory purposes
but you look at the standards which by
the way i think facebook did recently
publish them
last summer propublica got a trove of
these
criteria and i should put the word
standards and quotation marks
because the examples are they would be
laughable except that it's no laughing
matter so
uh facebook said if your talk and it
says it to this
army of thousands of people around the
world who are
enforcing these criteria uh that if
you're talking about
immigrants to a country because they
take each group
group by group about what you can say
and what you can't say
talk about speech codes i mean but so
about immigrants you may use the
adjective filthy about them but you may
not
use the noun filth about them
uh you may say things about them that
are degrading but you may not say things
about them that are
dehumanizing so okay well that clears
that clears it up yeah
on another level like how difficult is
it facebook is also i mean you know
they're a business twitter is a business
you know and they if they get a huge
amount of feedback saying like hey i
don't want to go on there
and and you know hear this kind of talk
like
i mean what you know you're you're
making an argument that they
should afford broad first uh amendment
protections all over the place but then
what if that hurts their business model
yeah so it you know i completely agree
that this is a
very difficult area which is why i just
you know skim the surface and in my book
and i think
but i think realistically this deserves
a lot of thought
i do believe that as a business they
have the prerogative to be responsive to
their shareholders uh but i think that
behooves the rest of us to be very
conscious of that and use whatever power
we have to push back as consumers and
some people now are arguing that
well we need to uh push for the
development of
alternative social media that will
perhaps be non-profit
so one of the arguments in the book a
large argument is that these
these laws are you know fundamentally
incoherent because it becomes so
subjective that it you know it's
ridiculous to try and define hate speech
in any kind of stable way
another is that these laws hurt the
people that they're
the the the speech rights of people who
they're supposed to protect
um then you also talk at a certain point
you uh what chapter six is
if the title is does constitutionally
protected hate speech
actually cause the feared harms what did
you find when you looked at the
literature
first of all i do have to underscore two
points about
matsuda and others who were pioneers in
making the argument about the psychic
and emotional harms of hate speech i
sincerely thank and acknowledge them
in the book because i think they made
drew our attention to
not only psychic impacts but also
physiological and
adverse impacts on free speech if you
feel so
um humiliated and disempowered you
are going to be stunned into silence so
those are serious concerns we're pushed
into weird violence right i mean
where you it's very exactly yeah however
i do have to point this out nick before
directly answering your question
and and that is that the argument
usually stops
there i mean even if we assumed for the
sake of argument that hate speech
inevitably caused harms it doesn't
necessarily follow
that censoring it is the right path
to reduce those harms because censorship
may be and i argue as we've already
discussed
that it is at best ineffective and
counterproductive and moreover
that counter speech and other
nonsensorial approaches
are more effective so my argument does
not rest
on only refuting the asserted harms
but let me address that that i think
that the difference between speech or a
major difference between
speech and other non-expressive conduct
is that speech cannot directly
cause harm it may potentially cause harm
but only through the intermediate
process intermediating processes
of the human mind right so i quote
eleanor roosevelt
in my book saying no one can make you
feel inferior without your consent
exactly and and many social
psychologists and mental health experts
are saying that
that you are not inevitably demeaned
just because somebody says something
hateful about you
and cognitive behavior therapists and
other experts say
we can and should teach ourselves and
teach our young students from a very
early age
to have the habits of mind and attitudes
and
resilience that they can withstand the
slings and arrows of
of hateful language and well this gets
to your uh you know to the final message
of
and you and you were alluding to it
where you know the the proper response
in your so i mean the cultural response
is to create a more robust society where
we can
take this and we can argue with more
counter speech
and things like that what are some of
the best ways to
address what people think of as hate
speech rather than you know having the
government say okay you're not allowed
to say that
and i think our we can see many examples
today i think today
it's hate mongers for example in
charlottesville who are the ones that
are
disparaged and looked down upon uh so
you have to look at the particular
context whatever the harm
potential harm is that you think the
speech could cause
you can nip that in the butt so if
you're concerned about
the feelings and the self-confidence and
the self-respect
of people who are disparaged you can
support
them you can argue in favor of their
equality you can denounce the ideas of
the haters
if you're concerned about the hate
mongers potentially recruiting
college students and others to be
supporters you reach out to those people
sometimes not necessarily through
rational arguments because
as we've been reading through some
celebrated cases it might have to do
with
something completely different such as
lack of friends and
being subject to bullying but there are
just remarkable examples online
and and elsewhere uh of people who
uh you know it's ordinary members of the
community as well as psychological
experts who have reached out to
even confirmed hate mongers even leaders
of
alt-right type white supremacist groups
and have
weaned them away from those beliefs and
from
that conduct there's a whole
organization one of many examples i
could cite
called life after hate which was founded
and is staffed by people who in the
prime of their life for many years
were members of hate groups themselves
and have come to see the light
you uh mentioned a 1984 incident at
harvard where a fraternity circulated a
misogynistic pamphlet
uh derek bach who was the president of
harvard at the time
said he wasn't going to punish these
guys but he
was also not going to like let it pass
unnoticed
why was that an exemplary response for
you to
how to deal with this kind of i liked
that derek bach example and there were
others in his administration because he
acknowledged the potentially chilling
effect
on speech of somebody in such a position
of authority as a university president
and he said i so he bent over backwards
to stress that there would be
absolutely no adverse consequence
for the students who express the
misogynistic or other hateful views
but he also said i have a responsibility
as the leader of an institution that
rejects those values
to make it clear that there is no
implicit endorsement to the
to the contrary so he was uh both
messages were equally important we def
and it really comes down to that famous
statement attributed
to voltaire i disagree with what you say
but i defend to the death you're right
to say it
but i'm also exercising my free speech
rights especially as the leader of this
community
to make clear on behalf of the uh the
university
as a whole that we reject the substance
of the message
not your right to say it briefly talk
about the larger culture you know
there seems to be a sense that we're
getting more and more
overly sensitive and you know we're
really polarized
and everybody's going off how do we
reinforce
a culture where it's kind of like
eleanor roosevelt eleanor roosevelt who
in a certain level was very privileged
obviously but also took a lot of [ __ ]
and she was a really
steadfast proponent of uh civil rights
and of
racial integration and whatnot like how
do we get back to that
more of an eleador roosevelt and less of
a kind of snowflake meant
and in my book i quote not only eleanor
roosevelt but a lot of african americans
including barack obama and van jones and
ruth simmons
because i think it's very especially
credible they would be more
credible uh role models to african
american students
it's so important to have the obamas and
the simmons and the van jones of the
world saying
you owe it to yourselves as individuals
and to the community that you're
representing to
develop the ability to withstand
whatever
efforts the hate mongers are engaging in
to try to silence you
to try to make you feel humiliated no
you've got to rise above that
and obama is constantly citing the
example of the civil rights
demonstrators in the 50s and 60s
martin luther king and others who kept
saying you know hate's not going to
drive out hate only love will do that
and learning to engage with those who
were
arguing against their civil rights
message by
hearing them and by responding to them
and you're not going to develop
effective arguments unless you listen to
them as well
randy kennedy who's an african-american
law professor at
at harvard a great advocate of civil
rights and civil liberties is working on
a whole book about this
uh and he's holding up the civil rights
movement as
and the students who were so active in
that movement
as a model to minority students today
that they are just not going to be
effective in achieving
their goals of reducing racial
discrimination and racial injustice
unless they learn to answer
back not allow themselves to be silenced
or
uh to feel demeaned but to make society
look down on those who are uh detracting
from
from their equal status well we will
leave it there we have been talking with
nadine strassen
she's a law professor law scholar and
former head of the aclu her latest book
is hate
why we should resist it with free speech
not censorship
nadine thanks thank you so much nick for
a reason i'm nick gillespie